she's at your voice psychobabble we are
back to that Island it's been a while I
have to say it has been a while I'm 30
[ __ ] remember the controls [ __ ] I'll
be here yep
you just figure out these girls real
quick
she agreed okay then holy [ __ ] holes
okay I guess we'll just [ __ ] and do this
let's just
girls real quick walk in Omaha that's
all I gotta say it's been a [ __ ] I'll
activate super mode no it's be okay last
night plays that wasn't on the [ __ ]
ex locked controllers were looking to be
a [ __ ] nightmare Wes
the best one push in the sky if this a
light phone very hard [ __ ] I [ __ ] it
now it's fast Java but
please young oh so it is here yeah let's
just do that suck and dad ass
yeah this may be [ __ ] bad for a wild
I figure out how to [ __ ] play this
anyone
I hear about to them but i did not say
about you them you're the wrong
Oh
huh
how do you just feel like I'm crazy
asset chef
Nick again okay
how do I not get tired again
remember uh what does every attack i do
like fun crazy
heck act macho upset how this [ __ ]
bit me
okay you're like that [ __ ]
a shed that
ain't not sad and okay and i truly not
remember this been way too long polish
at
shut get up bets wiecej throw mode on
okay god listen oyes [ __ ] heal up
yeah that's it oh I see
[ __ ] look is that about where I gotta
get out of this way we're taking the
wall route guys we're taking the wall
route yeah
yeah I need help
oh shut
I'm let me fall
I hear them
at
ouch
not your help analyze over there yeah
SS what is on
where are ya where are you betcha
if I come back here you bloody better
kill me it's not just throw a [ __ ]
knife at me
welcome through in life that may catch
yeah I got any way to have any healing
a lot of bricks but I don't see any
[ __ ] hate like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
hmm thank you
yeah that's any bad hell oh okay I gotta
plan my next move action go that way
Thank right I think I think Senor
begun I [ __ ] yeah why not you know y la
lab watts oh my laughs wants I like
these guys actually look twice I guess
come on get into frame no my daddy
hey might as well just knock thing
[ __ ] amaze was taken out wait do I have
anything to heal myself
yes
blueprints and I am she get out of luck
like this [ __ ] give me that money I
deserve it like looking over that money
welcome through me
and he's not [ __ ] out
I'm getting hurt over there
that's at
come on on the side of the lot closer
fremming
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that
especially I
it's a lot
[ __ ] is that noise
is this big boy uh-huh this guy hit on
my show break
ok Oh as long as I saw on
okay okay where's my like up in here
there is my weapon
okay time to get back on the horse and I
gotta go that way
I don't gone that way that's all I got
to say what
over here
Oh curvy let me get on the truck
yeah it's in restaurant right
I'm uh
careless match okay guys
a lot of money in these parts hey
darling
yeah I did not see that coming [ __ ] a
that's gay
all right thank you said yeah that's
yeah
[ __ ] health isn't I need
and I slicing on here
they sing out here
yeah this crystal here if you're waiting
to get served forget about my friends
packed up and left let me get you die I
want to hold up in some Haider heard
them talking about it somewhere in the
jungle they said meanwhile they leave me
here all pastors and Horace
like the quest
then I finishes I [ __ ] finished it
okay let me just make sure buys and
there's no like brats thing
oh okay we've been a [ __ ] alright thanks
for watching this one yes